Katie did you audition for the role of
Louise Vinnie passes mom I sort of
auditioned I been approached me and got
the script to me and we had conversation
about the part and we had several
conversations and then it was kind of a
mutual decision that I should come in I
said let me come in and read and let's
make sure it's right and so we did and
so yes it didn't really feel like not
Asian but I think it was an audition yes
okay and how was it for you to play this
version of a mother is I have to say at
first I didn't even know it was you it
was so different from other roles I've
seen many it was great I mean I like to
play very different roles and I had sort
of the the pictures of her the the
picture that was written in the script
of her as well as physical footage I had
of her made it easy to kind of fall into
what that would be and I loved working
on the accent I loved having a different
I'd like to transform I like all that
and I know that from the pressed notes I
believe it said that Louise didn't drive
she was pretty much homebound yes
wouldn't smoke in front of any so that
must have been very very different from
some of the other mothers that you
played how was it to kind of keep all
this stuff internal and then when you're
done shooting kind of go back to you I
mean it just seemed like it was a lot of
constraint right well you know what's
interesting I I think there's a part of
me as a mother because I have three
children of my own that is a little bit
naturally constraint around wanting to
know where my kids are at so what I know
about raising kids is sometimes you have
to contain yourself I mean for me so
that they can show you who they are so
it wasn't that difficult really and
actually in my own life I'm pretty
constrained well I was gonna ask you
that how done not very well
no okay the red wig was just one part of
that red okay no that's not who I am I
was wondering how you balance all that
because you're a performer you're singer
actress wife mother houses work balance
what what's the best reckon
datian in that situation just do what's
in front of you sort of you know you
know it's gotten easier over the years I
don't I I try not to travel too too
often because I do have a little one
also and you know it's all it's all good
it's what I always tell myself it's all
you know and it all gets done right and
lastly maintaining in an industry that
faces people out and you've been able to
thrive Wow thoughts thoughts on that
it's super grateful you know I I just
feel blessed about it that I continue to
work and that jobs come my way and and
and different and interesting kind of
jobs you know I feel like it keeps
getting you know I don't ascribe to the
fact that we as women as we get older
should be sort of disappearing and so
far I've been able to stay you know
viable so and III maybe it's sort of
like Vinnie Paz I refuse to believe
otherwise you know Vinnie Paz believed
that he would box again
I just believe I'll keep working thank
you thank you